si usted tiene hepatitis y su hígado
está inflamado porque usted ha sido
infectado con el virus de la hepatitis
su hígado es el órgano más grande dentro
de su cuerpo y realiza muchas funciones
importantes
las partes funcionales de su hígado son
llamadas lóbulos hepáticos sus lóbulos
hepáticos filtran toda la sangre en su
cuerpo
a medida que la sangre pasa a través de
ellos sus lóbulos hepáticos descomponen
sustancias dañinas
remueven bacterias y los glóbulos rojos
gastados
y forman factores de coagulación que
controlan el sangrado después de una
comida su hígado hace y almacena
nutrientes para proveer a su cuerpo con
energía cuando la necesita su hígado
también produce una sustancia llamada
bilis
su vesícula almacena bilis y la libera a
su intestino delgado para ayudar a
digerir grasas en los alimentos que come
si tiene hepatitis el virus ingresó a su
cuerpo cuando se expuso a sangre u otros
fluidos de una persona infectada con el
virus esto podría ocurrir a raíz de
compartir una jeringa de medicamento con
una persona infectada otros modos en que
usted puede estar expuesto al virus
incluyen tener sexo con alguien
infectado con el virus compartir
artículos de higiene personal como
rasuradoras o cepillos de dientes
utilizados por una persona infectada
contacto directo con la sangre o fluidos
corporales de una persona infectada o
cuando una madre lo pasa a un bebé
durante el nacimiento
durante la etapa temprana o aguda de la
infección de hepatitis la hepatitis se
ingresa a su hígado e invade sus células
hepáticas una vez dentro de sus células
hepáticas el virus comienza a hacer
copias de sí mismo durante el proceso de
copia cambios llamados mutaciones
ocurren frecuentemente en el material
genético del virus conduciendo a nuevas
cepas del virus en respuesta a la
infección viral su cuerpo envía células
inmunes para atacar tanto al virus como
a las células hepáticas infectadas con
el virus como resultado estas células
hepáticas se inflaman y mueren
con el tiempo se forma tejido
cicatrizante alrededor de las células
hepáticas muertas e infectadas el tejido
cicatrizante evita que su hígado trabaje
apropiadamente si tiene una infección de
hepatitis crónica su hígado contiene un
gran monto de tejido de cicatriz llamado
cirrosis lo que limita el flujo
sanguíneo y resulta en encogimiento
permanente y endurecimiento de su hígado
una vacuna contiene virus debilitados o
inactivos que entrenan a su sistema
inmune para reconocer y atacar ciertos
virus
sin embargo las mutaciones frecuentes en
la hepatitis hacen probable que usted
atrape una versión del virus que no está
contenida en una vacuna como resultado
no hay vacuna efectiva para el virus de
la hepatitis
si usted padece de hepatitis su sistema
inmune de por sí sólo destruirá todos
los virus de hepatitis de su cuerpo sin
embargo la mayoría de personas
infectadas con el virus desarrollan
hepatitis c crónica una condición en la
cual su sistema inmune no puede destruir
todos los virus en su cuerpo después de
seis meses si tiene hepatitis e crónica
y su sistema inmune no se puede deshacer
completamente del virus su médico puede
recetar una terapia de combinación que
consiste de un medicamento antiviral
llamado ribavirin e inyecciones de
interferón un medicamento que fortalece
su sistema inmune estos medicamentos son
mayormente efectivos contra la hepatitis
e cuando se toman juntos
si tiene un caso severo de hepatitis
crónica su médico puede recomendar una
operación de trasplante de hígado